Oh penis cap this wine is triumphant no
your vagina trumpets ah
I try and from the truth oh right of
course truth love it it's the best right
truth she seems cool everyone I promise
not to interrupt your tipple for long
but I just wanted to take reef moment to
welcome you to our funny little house
and to let our guests know that what
you're drinking is Hank Pierce's Break
bumper the recipe is still and no one
believes from the wallet of Teddy
Roosevelt's valet cheers everyone
yeah I'm actually gonna say no second
PhD right now and as a kind of studies
from the brown Wow sube double doctor
the second PhD is much harder yeah five
years is an absolutely gauntlet
I'm sure but just thank you once you're
done you won't have to waste the 12
seconds it takes to look up something on
Wikipedia but it seriously though no
well that's quite an achievement thank
you maater Roy mm-hmm Maxim Pierce all
right the man who would be king Don
Quixote of Iowa tilting it straw polls
yep I got a big old tent in everyone's
welcome
so are you in politics sort of Brookings
Institute ah Brookings yes of course
finally established oh I didn't take you
for a fan I thought you were on the
whole abolish the Federal Reserve
fluoride is poisoned pissing in jars and
of things no I'm actually on the liberty
and justice for all into things but hey
different strokes
mmm here comes Ken spiraling down Romy
oh yeah that's right from the oh the
thing where you tried to order my
family's legacy over the phone like a
new breed's of course burn how are you
that's the thing uh you know I'm well
I'm very well I'm uh working real hard
you know yeah yeah no not at all
really maybe who knows what do you meant
to say is that he's really passionate
about maintaining the integrity of the
customer-facing brands Wow
you